vis-à-vis de lui mais marlène schiappa
l'a souhaité tout à fait je dis pas que
c'est pas un débat à voir m'enfin c'est
pas spontanément à lui que je pense pour
ça le pauvre michel au caire il ya il se
retrouve toujours en galère lui faire
mal ou les posent une question qui le
dérange on passe à des relais repart qui
vous avez vous donner votre avis alors
déjà christophe barbier merci d'être là
et christophe vous franchement c'est une
mauvaise idée allons la mauvaise idée
c'est le débat oui voilà le débat il ya
14 jours entre les deux tours de la
présidentielle il ya des dizaines de
sujets à aborder
il ya des publics différents à toucher
les jeunes qui votent peu les acteurs
économiques les plus influents les
retraités les travailleurs pourquoi on
fait qu'un débat depuis 1970 ces
quelques il faudrait au moins trois
débats comme aux états unis comme aux
états unis dans trois styles différents
avec trois thématiques différentes
alors bien sûr un débat classique
institutionnels tf1 france 2 anne sophie
lapix gilles bouleau qui arbitre le face
à face comme on fait du shopping à
l'échelle 1 il faut ce deuxième débat
chaîne info parce que les chaînes info
peuvent organiser une sorte d' interview
un peu mitraillette comme ça avec toute
la série de thématiques avec des
spécialistes pour bien voir si les
candidats sont prêts sur chaque dossier
seriez prêt à le faire ça non je pense
faire mieux que moi non je vais
éditorialistes notre opinion non il ya
des intervieweurs c'est vraiment un
métier très particulier
et puis à côté de ça il faut un débat
qui avait cherché les jeunes qui les
intéressent à la chose politique qui les
amène au vote et qui permettent aussi
aux candidats de montrer des aspects de
leur personnalité que dans un débat plus
est plus classique il ne montre pas et
de ce côté là bas dans ce troisième
débat pourquoi pas pourquoi pas cyril
hanouna en effet quand vous voyez que
naquit c'est vrai que là qui valent un
peu là dessus
qu'est ce que vous leur dites je pense
qu'il faut qu'ils regardent le véritable
enjeu
le véritable enjeu c'est d'arriver à une
très très forte proportion de votants et
donc d'aller chercher les
abstentionnistes les abstentionnistes
dans notre société ils sont
essentiellement jeune et souvent pauvres
donc il faut trouver des modes de
communication qui attire les jeunes et
ceux qui sont tellement désespérés parce
que leur vie est difficile qui veulent
plus voter et tourne le dos à la
démocratie
on l'a vu au moment dé gilet jaune
qu'est-ce qu'il faut inventer comme mode
de communication pour ça déjà faut
refaire toutes les publicités
présidentielle c'est vous savez les
publicités par un pagne à st
salma rhin gassin en fait ce que les
leçons comment rude elles montrent pas
le droit d'être imaginatif support à la
publicité comparative pas demain que
finalement on n'a pas envie de les
regarder donc faut changer cette
communication des despotes officiel de
campagne
et puis il faut trouver des émissions de
radio de télé pour aller vers ces
populations là sans tomber dans le fait
que le guennic le jeu il s'agit pas de
se moquer de la politique et c'est là où
ça commence à être difficile pour cyril
hanouna
parce que si l'animal ces débats il ne
peut pas être l'animateur de l'émission
c'est pas son émission il n'est plus lui
d'un seul cool
le moteur de l'émission non le moteur
c'est la démocratie
c'est l'enjeu républicain ce sont les
deux candidats et doit se mettre au
service de l'instant démocratique qu'il
a l'honneur de coanimer alors grâce et
un c'est un autre métier dick